As you know, in Linux they use the term task to signify a schedulable entity.
And so, we're using T1, T2, T3, to mean tasks, which are
schedulable entities. And the timer-q data structure, what it contains is the
tasks and the expiry time for that particular task. And the tasks are ordered in
this Timer-q data structure maintained by the kernel, sorted
by the expiry time. So task T1 is the
earliest task to go off. Because it has the
earliest expiry time. T2 is next, with an expiry time
of 12. T3 with an expiry time of 15 and so on. So this is the way the kernel
is maintaining the data structure to know when a
particular task's expiry time is up for processing the event
associated with that particular task. The basis for firm timer implementation
is the availability of APIC hardware.
APIC is advanced programmable interrupt controller,
which is implemented on chip in modern CPU starting from Intel Pentium
onwards, and the firm timer implementation in TS-Linux takes advantage of the
APIC hardware. The good news is with
the APIC timer hardware, re-programming a one shot
timer takes only a few cycles. So there
is not a significant overhead to re-programming a
one shot timer on modern CPUs because of the availability of the APIC hardware.
So if the task that is at the head of the queue, that had it's timer event go
off, if it has to be reprogrammed, all that we need to do is
execute a few instructions in modern processes
to reprogram that one shot timer to go
off at the next one shot interval. When the APIC timer
expires, the interrupt handler will go through this timer-q
data structures and look for tasks whose timers have expired.
Some of these tasks may be periodic tasks, some of these tasks may have been
programmed to deal with the APIC timer
event. So, associated with each entry in this
timer queue data structure is the callback
handler for dealing with that particular event. And
those callback handlers are going to be
called by the interrupt handler upon the expiry
of the APIC timer. The expired timers are going to be removed from those timer
queue data structures. If the entry corresponds to
a periodic timer, then the handler will re
enqueue that particular task in the timer
queue data structure after updating its expiry field
for the next periodic event for that task. If it is a one shot timer that
this task was using. In that case, the interrupt handler will reprogramme that
task for the next one short event. The way the APIC timer hardware works is
by setting a value into register which is decremented at each memory bus cycle
until it reaches zero. At which point it'll generate an interrupt. Now given a
100 megahertz memory bus, for instance, on modern CPUs, a one short timer has
a theoretical accuracy of ten nanoseconds. However,
in practice, the time needed to feel
the timer interrupt is significantly higher. And
that becomes the limiting factor in the
granularity that you can get with one
shot timers implemented using the APIC hardware.
But the important point is that APIC hardware allows you to implement very fine
grained timers in modern processes. And as I already mentioned, by choosing an
appropriate overshoot parameter in reprogramming the epic
timer. We can eliminate the need for
fielding one shot interrupts, because of soft
timers going off within that overshoot period.
Another optimization that we can do, in the
firm time at implementation, is looking at the distance
between one shot events. For instance, in this
picture I'm showing you, the long distance between two
one shot events. There is a one shot
event happening here. There is a one shot timer
event happening here. Another one shot timer event happening
here. And if you have such a long distance,
it is possible that there may be several
periodic timer events that may be going off
within this long distance. So this suggests that
if periodic events are going to go off, and
if it is close enough to a one shot timer that would have gone off, why not take
advantage of that? So what we want to do is dispatch a one shot event at
a preceding periodic event. The key thing for
time sensitivity is not missing the timer event.
If you're going to process it a little
bit sooner, that's okay. So that's exactly what
is happening here. Just as in the case
of the overshoot parameter being used in combing
one shot to the soft timer. What we're
doing here is, because periodic timers are going
to interrupt anyhow and if the kernel notices
that there is a one shot event that is
coming up fairly soon, then it can simply dispatch
that one shot event at the preceding periodic timer
event that is any how accepting the processor. And
once you do that, then you can reprogram this
one shot event to go off at the next
expiry point for that one shot event. So basically,
what we're doing when we have a long distance between one shot events,
is to use a preceding periodic timer event, so that we can both avoid the
overhead of dealing with this one shot event. And also the cost of reprogramming
it. Or in other words, we completely
eliminate using one shot events for situations
where the distance between the one shot events is so big that we can simply use
the periodic event instead of the one shot
event. And the reasons for doing that are twofold.
One is, periodic event data structures are much
more efficient than the kernel, they're order of one
data structures. Whereas, the one shot event programming
data structures in the kernel. Tends to be order
of log n, where n is the number of active timers. So as an optimization,
if the one shot events happen at fairly long distances. That there are several
periodic events that are going to happen
anyhow within that. We will simply use the
periodic timers instead of the one shot
timer. So to summarize, the firm timer implementation.
The first point is that the APIC hardware allows reprogramming one shot timers
in few cycles. And secondly, by choosing
the appropriate overshoot distance, we can eliminate
the need for fielding the one shot timer interrupts if soft timers go off within
that overshoot period. And third, if the distance between one shot timers is
really long, then instead of using one shot timers, we will simply
use periodic timers and dispatch the one shot
event at the preceding periodic timer event. Those are the ideas that
are enshrined in the firm timer implementation in TS-Linux, that
essentially combines the advantages of one shot timer with
soft timers with periodic timers. So this should give you a feel
for how TS-Linux, by a clever implementation,
reduces the timer latency, the first component of the
latency from the point of event happening to event activation.